[Music]
your kid even versus walls around you
you think that you'll always be
protected and cared for then one day you
realize that's not true because when
you're alone as a kid
the master CU is weaker you don't even
know they're getting closer till it's
too late
my grandfather thinks this town is
cursed
that all the bad things that happen in
this town because of one thing an evil
thing come with me - I saw something Oh
clam yeah I saw him too what happens
when another Georgie goes missing are
you just gonna pretend it isn't
happening like everyone else in this
town if you stick together
[Music]
[Music]
when you're a kid I think that you'll
always be protected
cared for we like hanging with you
Thanks shouldn't think it's too much
hanging out with us makes you a loser
too
but when you're alone as a kid
[Music]
the master Cu is weaker
you don't even know they're getting
closer until it's too late
what we're supposed Navy nowhere okay
well I'm starting to get it cheap and
I'm pretty sure this is not the same
bathroom where's your mother
sometimes yeah then you probably have
crabs it's so not funny aren't you girls
coming in ah it's great water what the
hell is gray water
it's basically piss and [ __ ] so I'm just
telling you you guys are splashed around
and millions of gallons of dairy pee so
what are you are you serious what it
doesn't smell like a cop to me Senor
have you ever heard of a staph infection
also that's so unsanitary
you're literally this is Lou heart
keeping inside of a toilet bowl right
now here are the reason why we're in
this position my daughter whose sneaker
is it it's Betty rips oops what if she's
still here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go she's already captain
thanks Louie
[Music]
[Music]
Jerry's not like any time I've ever been
in before people Dyer disappeared six
times the national average
that's just gross kids are worst way way
worse I saw something there is this
yeah I saw him - look it's all connected
by the sewers that's where it lives
[Music]
[Music]
oh if you'll come with me don't flip too
[Music]
[Music]